[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
My name is Reto Meier.
Welcome to "This Week in
Android Development" on
Monday, August 19, 2013.
Last week, the Android Developer
Relations team
visited London, serving up some
knowledge to students at
Android Camp and introducing the
GDG London to the world of
Android gaming.
On this side of the pond, Chet
was back again for a look at
using cartoon animation
techniques in a brand new
"DevByte." While further south,
our Australian-based
colleagues invited you backstage
for a Q&A on how to
make your apps beautiful.
When not backstage, JF was front
and center, showing us
how to optimize layouts
with Hierarchy Viewer.
And our favorite intern told us
everything we need to know
about image pixelization.
Next week, we have a flood of
new "DevBytes" for you,
starting with a guide to
ListView dragging and
rearranging with Daniel,
ensuring your apps work on
large display devices.
And a new series of "DevBytes"
from yours truly as I explain
how to make your data transfers
more efficient.
For fans of the longer format,
we've got a new "Android
Design in Action" this week.
And Hack and Todd will be
getting their game on on a new
episode of "Game On!" They
will introduce you to the
wonderful world of
OpenGL ES 3.0.
That's all for "This Week in
Android Development." Be sure
to check out this week's
"DevBytes." And join us for
our live shows which you
can find, as always, at
developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
And everyone is waiting,
waiting on you.